a BLM activist a co-founder of a BLM
chapter is endorsing Donald Trump we've
been used and abused for so long that
party they don't value our vote uh their
policies are basically um racist
policies and I believe it's a racist
party Donald Trump is he's the opposite
he's he's gonna tell you how it is he's
gonna give it to you straight Trump has
done more for the black community than I
can any president I can think of in my
lifetime and he's not alone in his
criticism President Biden faces dismo
approval numbers among black voters in
key swing States joining us now the
co-founder of black lives matter Road
Island Mark fiser Mark thanks so much
for joining the program um you know this
is my favorite story of the day because
it identifies with what I've seen in the
barber shop all the brothers for some
reason right now are turning Tides right
now and I I just wonder what is the big
reason I think personally it's the
duplicity of the Democrat
the hypocrisy um we're not stupid the
brothers are not stupid we we understand
when someone's for us and when someone
is not okay so this
guy is saying look I used to be a big
BLM supporter but now I'm supporting
Donald Trump the way the way that
Trump's opponents and the Republican
Party are framing this is that Trump is
embracing BLM that's not really the case
this guy Mark fiser is saying yeah I'm
not I'm not really a BLM activist
anymore I I left the left because
they're racist and it's they're not
helping black people and the black
people now are all going to start voting
for Republicans I hope this is the case
I I hope this happens I'm not holding my
breath for it because I've heard this
just about every single election cycle
of my lifetime I've heard this is going
to be the one where the Democrats lose
the black vote and it moves in a big
swing to the Republicans and it never
happens it never ever happens the
Democrats keep a roughly 90% hold on on
the black vote and I'm I'm looking at
the same polling that everybody else is
I agree right now in the polling you are
seeing a big swing among black voters es
especially among black men toward the
Republican Party toward Trump I agree
that if any candidate is going to shake
up the demographic voting patterns it's
going to be Trump because he's a weirdo
because he doesn't fit the mold of the
old Republican politicians so there's a
decent enough chance that the voters are
going to break that mold too for him I'm
just not holding my breath for it but
that's not even why I bring up this
story I bring up this story because of
what I think is a fairly dishonest
attack on Trump right now go to P
talk.com Pure Talk has you covered for
the holidays with a free Moto G 5G phone
no gimmicks no trade in necessary just
sign up for Pure talks unlimited talk
unlimited text and 15 gigs of data you
can get all of this for just 35 bucks
and you will get the Moto g5g phone for
free here's the deal you need to move
fast because these phones are almost
gone so if your current phone is on life
support upgrade for free with pure talk
the new Moto g5g boasts a 2-day battery
life an exceptional quad pixel camera
and a whole lot more peer talk gives you
America's most Dependable 5G Network at
half the price make the switch today go
to Pur
talk.com kwes to get this exclusive
offer and select the plan that is right
for your family palk gives you America's
most Dependable 5G Network at half the
price so make the switch today Pur
talk.com NES kwes to claim your free
Moto g5g phone with a qualifying plan
Pure Talk simply smarter Wireless right
now go to genucell.com we all know the
holidays can be a little bit hectic the
shopping the cooking the never- ending
list of things to do but fear not
because I have discovered a gift that is
thoughtful and transformative the gift
of genus cell skincare from now until
Christmas genu cell's most popular
package has a special discount for our
listeners at jus.com
treat yourself and your loved ones to
the absolute best skincare in the world
those troubling forehead wrinkles Fine
Lines skin redness and sagging jawline
will disappear right before your eyes
with genell's most popular collection
you will see results in less than 12
hours guaranteed or your money back you
deserve to look and feel your best this
Christmas season go to jus.com love the
company you know the founder is a Coptic
Christian from Egypt who left for the
American
dream jus.com get this incredible
holiday discount every order is
instantly upgraded to free Express
shipping that is genucell.com
nwle this is the top quality stuff out
there incredible deals because they know
that you are going to be a customer for
life that's how good it is jus.com
and it's the headline Trump Embraces BLM
because he sent out this post on Truth
social spoke with Mark fiser yesterday a
great guy very honored to have his and
blm's support I've done more for black
people than any other president Lincoln
in in parenthesis Lincoln including
10year funding for historically black
colleges and universities where they had
none opportunity zones Criminal Justice
Reform and much more thank you to
Mark
so I see why people are accusing Trump
of embracing
BLM but I think that this post on Truth
social is a roar shock test I don't
think it really tells you any new
information about Trump I think this is
a roar shock test for whether or not you
like Trump or you just hate Trump that's
what it's really about because one way
of reading it is Donald Trump is honored
to have blm's support this guy's a
leftist he's a radical latinum the other
way to read this is Donald Trump is a
funny guy who's doing a little bit of
trolling and making a
joke I think it's pretty clearly the
latter here's my evidence because one
sentence after he says he's honored
first of all because he doesn't have BLM
support because this guy left BLM and
BLM no longer recognizes him so I see
that as a fact that is a little trollish
the very next sentence Trump says I've
done more for black people than any
other president now the obvious response
to that is well Lincoln freed the slaves
are you Donald really saying that you've
done more than Abraham Lincoln and Trump
he's not even unaware of that he
acknowledges that in this jokey way in
the Tweet I've done more than any other
president for black people Lincoln
question question mark not even okay
other than Abraham Lincoln no no he says
no I've actually I think I've done more
for black people even than the president
who freed the
slaves I don't I think he's joking I
think the 40-year Entertainer who had a
top show on network television and has
been a an entertaining comedic figure
for almost half a century now I think he
knows how to tell a
joke now he cites certain things here
that I don't like the Criminal Justice
Reform that jailbreak bill I I did not
like that that was a bad policy so I I
grant that there is sometimes a little
bit of a mixed bag here but I guess I
guess that's even my broader point to
why this tweet or this truth social post
doesn't upset
me we have in the case of trump a record
to look at does anybody really believe
that Donald Trump is going to invite BLM
to the White House we're going to have
Secretary of State Patrice
cullers
Secretary of the Interior Alicia Gara I
don't think
so Trump very clearly stood against that
kind of radicalism obviously but he
speaks in ways that are kind of
ambiguous and often just funny on the
campaign Trail what I would compare this
to is When Donald Trump waved the LGBT
flag on the campaign Trail you remember
that LGBT for Trump and he actually had
the flag upside down because he
obviously doesn't care about that issue
at all and a lot of people a lot of
conservatives said this guy he's a
radical Pro LGBT candidate he's a big
leftist how could conservatives even
consider endorsing him or voting for him
and what some people said at the time
was yeah he's just he's just happy to
take people's votes but he's not going
to be a pro LGBT rights activism
president or whatever and then he wasn't
he gets into office and he immediately
reverses Barack Obama's insane decision
to promote in the military he was just
an ordinary president he promoted
conservative Jud Jes to the courts he
didn't he wasn't that he talked in one
way on the campaign trail that was
weaponized ambiguity that won votes that
got attention and then he governed in a
way that was basically solid and that is
what I think we're seeing here with Mr
Trump and
BLM man what a great clip that was now
hey whoa hold up ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel see you next time